The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT open courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Now if you
looked at today's notes,
you'll notice that they're
very long and very complicated.
And that's not intended
to be intimidating.
It's just to show you the
power of perturbation theory.
So we have talked about
the two-level problem.
The two-level problem is
one that's exactly solved.
It's one of our favorite
exactly solved problems,
although it doesn't seem to
have any physical relevance.
It's just a nice
numerical exercise.
So we can take a two
by two Hamiltonian
and exactly diagonalize it.
And that's done
using a unitary--
or actually, in the
case that we looked at,
orthogonal-- transformation.
And so it's a rotation
in state space.
And the rotation angle
is an explicit function
of the parameters
in the Hamiltonian.
Now all good things
come to an end.
We cannot do this for anything
more than a two-level problem.
But we can take the formalism
for the two-level problem
and say, oh, well,
we can describe
a transformation that
diagonalizes the end level
problem.
And it has the same
property of being unitary.
But the good thing about it
is it's solved by a computer.
You tell a computer
what the operator is,
and it will diagonalize it.
And not only will
it diagonalize it,
but it will give
you the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors.
It gets those eigenvectors by
applying the same two level
unitary transformation
many, many times.
So if you have a
six-level problem
or a hundred-level
problem, the computer
just cranks and cranks
on each two by two
and does transformations.
And it keeps doing that
until the off diagonal matrix
element is small--
remaining off diagonal
matrix element--
is small compared
to the difference
in energy between the
eigenvalues it connects.
And so you tell it, I want
this convergence criterion
to be a part in a hundred
or a part in a million.
And it just does
this and does this.
And eventually, it gives
you the transformation
and the eigenvalues.
So that means that it doesn't
matter how big the problem is.
You just have to have a
computer that's patient or fast.
And it will crank
out the results.
Now you need to know how to use
the t matrices, or the t dagger
matrix, because these things
enable you to solve basically
any problem in time
independent quantum mechanics
and a lot of problems in time
dependent quantum mechanics.
So there is another
way, and that's
going to solve an
n-level problem.
And that's the subject of this
lecture and the next lecture.
It's called non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
Now our goal-- well, let's ask.
I'm a spectroscopist.
What do spectroscopists do?
Now, there's a silly,
stupid answer to that.
I want something a
little more profound.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Find energy levels?
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah,
we record spectra.
We get energy levels.
And we get intensities.
We get all sorts of things.
We could also be working in
the time domain, and we could
we could be looking at some
kind of quantum beating
system or some decaying system.
We make these measurements.
But this is not why we do it.
Remember, yes--
AUDIENCE: All spectra
have buried information
about the physical
parameters of the system.
ROBERT FIELD: Exactly, exactly--
that's what's kept me
going for my entire career.
I use the word encoded
rather than buried.
But I like that.
I might start using
buried as well.
Yes, we're not allowed to
look inside of small things.
We're not allowed to
determine the wave
function by any experiment.
But we are able to observe the
energy levels and properties
of the Hamiltonian.
And we can regard
the Hamiltonian
as a fit model, a model where
there are adjustable parameters
which are the structural
parameters, like the force
constants and the reduced
masses and whatever
we need to describe
everything in this problem.
And today's lecture
is mostly going
to be on the interactions
between normal modes
of a polyatomic molecule.
Now you might ask, why am I
doing this rather than talking
about just an ordinary,
anharmonic oscillator.
And the reason is, I'm going
to do that in the next lecture.
And it's in your problem sets.
You're going to do that.
So I'm going to show a little
higher order of information.
So we go from what
we can observe
to a representation
of it, which we
call the effective
Hamiltonian, where
in this effective Hamiltonian
we have determined
the values of all of
the important structural
parameters.
And from that, we can calculate
everything, everything
that we could possibly
observe, including
things we didn't observe.
So it's really powerful.
It's a way of taking the
totality of observations
that you're going
to make and saying,
yes, I have looked
inside this molecule.
And I've determined everything
that I'm allowed to determine.
And I can calculate
the wave function.
The wave function is an
experimentally determined wave
function, but only indirect.
This is amazingly powerful.
And basically, everybody
who deals with spectra
is doing this whether
they know it or not.
And so I want to be able
to give you the tools
to be able to take any arbitrary
spectrum and extract from it
the crucial information.
In the last lecture,
we talked a little bit
about matrix mechanics, and
that involved linear algebra.
And you have a wonderful
handout on linear algebra, which
will give you more
than enough to be
able to do any quantum
mechanical problem we're going
to be facing in this class.
And there is notation.
And the notation is
unfamiliar, and you
have to learn how to use it.
And so we have for example--
the analogy to the Schrodinger
equation in matrix language--
where we have the Hamiltonian,
an eigenvector, an eigenvalue,
and this eigenvector.
So it's an eigenvalue
or eigenvector equation.
And this is the form of
the Schrodinger equation
and we can pretend that it is
the real Schrodinger equation.
And we can use the
standard approaches,
but it's useful to work
in matrix notation.
So we can solve for
the energy levels,
and we can solve for basically
all of the eigenvectors.
And our friend is this
unitary transformation where
t dagger is equal to t inverse.
And t times t inverse is
equal to this thing 1111100,
or the unit matrix.
I thought I saw a hand up.
That was just-- that
was not serious.
And so these unitary
transformations
have this special
convenient property.
And we use these
t daggers and ts
to diagonalize the Hamiltonian.
Now this is just a
little bit of review.
So how did we derive the thing
that we are going to solve?
Well, we took this
equation and we inserted 1
between the Hamiltonian
and the vector.
And then this is 1.
So we don't need to
put it over here.
And then we left
multiply by t dagger,
and we put parentheses
around things.
So this is now what we
were calling h tilde.
And this is c tilde.
And this is now an
equation that says, OK, we
can transform the Hamiltonian
into diagonal form--
E1, En, zeros.
And when we have this
in diagonal form,
we can say, well, this equation
is just E1, 100 et cetera.
So for any eigenvalue,
we have an eigenvector.
Now what we'd really
like to know is, well,
how do we get these eigenvectors
from the unitary transformation
that diagonalizes H. We don't
calculate this unitary-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that i or--?
ROBERT FIELD: This is a 1,
this is a 1, this is a 1.
AUDIENCE: I mean in your c
tilde, third from the top.
ROBERT FIELD: That's a j.
This is a particular
eigenvalue, and this
is the eigenvector in that.
Now it's easy for me
to get screwed up,
and it's easy for you to wonder,
what the hell am I doing,
until you've done it.
And then it's
completely transparent.
It's really quite simple.
But it's just this
extra notation.
And so it's possible to show--
and I don't want to do it.
I did it last time.
You can show-- and
this is important--
that this transformation
t dagger c equals c.
Do I want?-- above, above.
This is telling you that
the columns of t dagger
are the eigenvectors.
They are linear combination
of the basis vectors
that correspond to
each eigenvector.
And you can look at this in
more detail in the notes.
Now this is great
because mostly you
want to know what
the eigenvectors are
for a particular eigenvalue.
But sometimes, when
you're doing dynamics,
you prepare, not an
eigenvector, but you
prepare a t equals
0, a basis state.
This is the most
common, doable problem,
and it's also something that
one does in experiments.
You can set up a problem so
that, with a short pulse,
you prepare the system at
t equals 0 in something
that's not an eigenstate.
And usually it's a basis state--
it's one of the eigenvalues
of an exactly solved problem.
But your problems are
not exactly solved ones,
but your experiment
selects that.
And this, not being
an eigenstate,
needs to be expressed
as a linear combination
of eigenstates so
that you can actually
calculate this,
which will describe
how the system is behaving.
And I like asking exam
problems like this
because it's easy to
get hopelessly involved
in ordinary algebra rather
than just using linear algebra.
So if this is the transformation
to the eigenbasis,
then the columns of t are
the transformation back
to the 0 order bases.
And the columns of t are
the rows of t dagger.
Now why should you care?
Because you don't know how to
calculate the elements of the t
matrices yet, but that's what
perturbation theory is for.
With perturbation
theory, it doesn't
matter that the computer could
solve for the t and t dagger
matrices.
But there's no insight.
You just get the numbers.
I like to say that
spectroscopy is not
about creating archival tables
of observed transitions and
observed transition intensities.
It's about understanding
how things work.
And so depending on whether
you're doing a time domain
experiment or frequency
domain experiment,
you're going to want to use
either the columns of t dagger
or the rows of t dagger.
Now at some point
in your life, you
have to be exposed to
non-degenerate perturbation
theory because it
is really powerful.
But it's also incredibly ugly.
So we have a whole
bunch of problems--
I'll go over here--
that are related to
the particle in a box
or the particle in an infinite
box or the harmonic oscillator.
And so one of the
things that you might do
is round off the corners
because physical systems don't
have discontinuities.
Well, that's going to be a very
modest change to the energy
levels and wave functions.
Another thing you might
do is have a barrier,
and you could put
the barrier anywhere.
What does the barrier
or an extra well do?
Or you could do
something like this.
So the particle-in-a-box is a
whole family of problems that
you could solve using
perturbation theory by saying,
OK, the extra stuff
is the perturbation.
And we have to work
out the matrix elements
of the Hamiltonian
that correspond
to these extra things
and then figure out
what to do to get the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions.
Now, for the
harmonic oscillator--
again, you could put a
barrier in the middle
or you could make it an
asymmetric like almost
all molecular potentials are,
where this is dissociation
and this is two closed cells
colliding with each other
and doing very hard repulsion.
And so that is harmonic
near the bottom,
but it's not harmonic elsewhere.
And so how do you
represent this?
And the Morse oscillator
is a cheap way
of generating something
with this shape
and then doing the perturbation
theory to understand
how the nonharmonic
aspect of the Morse
can affect the energy levels.
Or how did the energy levels
determine, say, the association
energy of this molecule?
How is that dissociation energy
encoded in the energy level
pattern?
Now for polyatomic molecules,
if you have n atoms,
there are 3n minus 6
vibrational normal modes.
Well, how do I know that?
n atoms, there's 3n
degrees of freedom.
There's 3 translations
and 3 rotations.
And so that leaves 3n minus 6.
And all of that is vibrations.
So we have many normal modes,
and it's not too surprising
that, if you stretch
one normal mode,
it'll affect the
frequency of another.
And we'd like to know that.
And so perturbation
theory is really
valuable for
polyatomic molecules.
And that's the bulk
of the examples
that I worked in the non-lecture
notes for this lecture.
But there's also dynamics.
So you prepare some
initial state of t equals 0
and you want to know
how it's evolving.
But often that initial state
is an eigenstate of one
of the exactly solved problems.
And you want to be
able to re-express
that in terms of the
eigenstates of the real problem.
And so you want to know C J--
I'm sorry.
You want to know
J, CJ eigenstates.
So once you have
this, then you know
how to write the
time dependent wave
function because you are
dealing with eigenstates
and they have eigenenergies.
And so you just
write this thing out.
It's just mechanical and boring.
It's also true that
molecules rotate.
And when they rotate,
there's centrifugal force
and their internuclear
distances change.
And we can then
calculate how that
will affect the rotational
energy levels using
perturbation theory.
And then there's
the origin of life.
Gases are not
supportive of life.
You need two particles to
come together and start
to condense into a liquid.
That's the beginning.
Perturbation theory explains
the long range interactions
by which all gas phase particles
attract each other weakly.
So that's important too.
And so you'll be able
to do all of this stuff.
So here we have non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
And it is a mind numbing,
formal derivation.
So we start out with
this rotary equation.
And we say, well, let us
expand the Hamiltonian.
And let's put a
little thing here.
This is our friend.
This is an exactly
solved problem.
This is what's new, and this
is what's new and small.
And we could
probably neglect it.
And we do the same thing
to the energy levels.
So these are the energy levels
for the exactly solved problem.
And these are the
energy levels--
the first order
corrected energy levels.
And these are the second
order corrected energy levels.
And we do the same thing
for the wave function.
Now we write the Schrodinger
equation with these three term
expressions.
Now I'm also going
to say, we're never
going to consider
this one either.
So life is simpler without
them, but in the notes,
I included them all.
And so what we do is now
we write the full equation
and we sort it into sub
equations corresponding
to powers of lambda.
So the lambda to the 0
equation is really easy.
It's just H0 psi 0
is equal to E0 psi 0.
We could put n's on this.
And this is the
exactly solved problem.
It says, yeah, you
build your foundation
from the lambda to
0 equation, and it's
just what you know already.
And what you're going to do is
now use the psi n 0 and en 0
to do everything else.
The lambda to the one equa--
well, you might ask,
well, what is lambda.
It's just a mathematical trick.
It has no significance
whatsoever.
It's a smallness
parameter, but it's also
something where you can
say, these equations
will be true for
any value of lambda.
And so it's just a way of
separating the equations
into things that have
a structure that you
can manipulate.
People have waxed eloquent
about the meaning of lambda,
and it really doesn't
have any meaning.
So the lambda to the
1 equation-- well,
we collect terms on the left
hand side that have 1 lambda
and on the right hand side.
And so the lambda
to the 1 equation
is going to be, say, H0
psi 1 is equal to E0 psi 1.
I'm sorry.
There's more to it than that.
There's four terms.
We're just collecting
the terms that
have 1 lambda on the left-hand
side and right-hand side.
And we've got this equation.
What are we going to do with it?
Well, one thing we can do with
it is multiply on the left.
Let's just put
some indices here.
So we have n, n, n.
We're going to multiply on the
left and integrate by psi n 0.
So we're going to
get a bunch of terms.
So we will have psi n 0 H 0 psi
n 1 plus psi n 0 H 1 psi n 0.
We have integral, integral.
And on the left hand side,
we have E n 0 integral psi n
0 psi n 1.
And we have E 1 psi n 0 psi n 0.
Well, this is kind
of an ugly term.
It's a psi 0 and a psi 1.
But we know that H, when
operating on psi 0, gives E 0.
So we're going to get E n 0
integral psi n 0 psi n 1--
same two over here.
Cancel them.
And so we get a simple equation
that is just H1 n n is equal to
E1 n.
So we've gotten now
the diagonal matrix
element of the
perturbation term is
equal to the first-order
correction to the energy.
And we can continue.
The algebra isn't beautiful, but
we end up getting the following
equations.
We have E n 1 is H 1 nm.
We have psi n 1 is m not
equal to n psi m 0 H nm.
So what did I do here?
I said, the wave function--
we have completeness.
So if we want the first order
corrections to the nth wave
function, we can write this as
a linear combination of the zero
order wave functions.
And when we do that, we
end up with this formula.
This is the mixing coefficient,
and these are the state-- now
why do I exclude n?
Because we already have it.
And then we get the
second-order correction
to the energy, which is m
not equal to n h n m 1 H m n
1 over En 0.
That's it.
That's all we need.
Now it does say non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
And so it's subject
to the requirement
that H1 n m over E n minus E m.
So if the energy
denominator is near 0,
we know we're in trouble.
But for the vast majority
of energy levels,
this term is much less than 1.
And so that means we can deal
with all of the interactions
among the non-degenerate
levels in one fell swoop.
Now this is an infinite sum,
and this is an infinite sum.
So we don't like infinities.
But we can say, all right,
here's the Hamiltonian.
It's an infinite Hamiltonian.
And we're interested in
this little corner of it.
And so all of the interactions
among these states with all
of the infinite
others get subsumed
into this infinite sum.
It's a small number.
And then we're just interested
in this little subspace
of the energy levels that we're
sampling in our experiment.
So the molecule more
or less tells you
how to focus on the
part that you care about
and to get rid of the stuff that
is of no trouble whatsoever.
And it just contaminates the
wave functions a little bit.
And if you wanted to know
what that contamination is,
you could deal with it.
So this is the tool that you
can use to solve, basically,
any problem involving
molecules with a potential
like a harmonic
oscillator at the bottom.
But it's usable
for all problems,
but there's a different
basis set rather than
the harmonic
oscillator basis set.
So this is your handy dandy key.
And you don't need a
computer, although when
you see the horrible
complexity that
will result when you start
dealing with these sums,
you will say, well, I do
want to use a computer.
But now it's up to me
to organize the program
so that you can ask
the computer to do
what you need in a sensible way
and you still get good answers.
So in the notes, I'm dealing
with a two-mode molecule.
There are no two-mode molecules.
There's one-mode
molecules, and there
might be three or four
or six or whatever.
But the complexity is the
interaction between two modes.
And so we're going
to talk about that.
So we have for a
two-mode molecule--
the Hamiltonian will
consist of Hamiltonian
for mode 1,
Hamiltonian for mode 2,
and the Hamiltonian
for modes 1 and 2,
interacting with each other.
Well, we know these.
These are just ordinary
harmonic oscillator.
And we've got to do
some work on this.
And that's where
perturbation theory comes in.
So H12-- and we know,
if this weren't here,
we know that the
energy levels are
that some of the energy
levels for the two
independent oscillators
and the wave functions
are the products.
So even though the energy levels
have two quantum numbers, V1
and V2, and the wave functions
have two quantum numbers,
V1 and V2, if it
were only this, we'd
have completely
solved that problem.
But because of this,
there's something else.
So these then turn out
to be the zero order
states that you use to evaluate
all the integrals here.
And we have these and A
and A dagger operators,
which are enabling us to--
we have the operator
for coordinate
x is proportional
to A plus A dagger.
And this has a selection rule,
delta V of plus and minus 1.
So we like these
things because we
don't have to do any integrals.
They're all done for you.
And so we're then going to
use these sorts of things
to deal with the most important
terms beyond harmonic.
And so there's a cubic
and there is a quartic.
And although you
haven't really explored
this, what happens when you
make dimensionless coordinates?
You factor out something.
And if you have
cubic terms, they're
100 times smaller
than quadratic terms.
And the quartic terms
are 100 times smaller
than the cubic terms.
And so you don't need
to go much further.
So the cubic terms for
the two oscillators
would be 1/2 K 122 Q1 Q2 squared
plus 1/2 K 112 Q 1 squared Q2.
And you could have Q1
cubed, but we already
deal with that in the
single-mode problem.
So we won't worry about that.
So these are the couplings
between modes 1 and 2
that are cubic.
And then we have 1/4 k 112
Q 1 squared Q 2 squared.
There's also a Q1 Q2 cubed,
and those terms usually
are not important
because they mostly
are dealt with under here.
So anyway, these
are the parameters,
and these are the things
that you need in order
to understand what
this molecule is
going to do when it's excited.
Now when I was a
graduate student,
there was a great deal of
excitement about doing what's
called mode-specific chemistry.
Ordinary compounds cost on
the order of $1 a kilogram.
But if you could do
mode specific chemistry,
you could make
things that aren't
makeable by ordinary,
organic chemistry.
And the organic
chemists would love this
because it's a load of garbage
because these guys make
the modes talk to each other.
And so even if you
could excite a pure
overtone or combinational
level, the energy
moves around the molecule.
And that's called
intermolecular, vibrational
redistribution.
And those there are
processes that you
could talk about the
primary paths for the energy
to flow and the rates.
And that was a major area of
research for the last 30 years.
And most people are tired of it.
But it started out being IVR,
yeah, anything can happen.
It's statistic or whatever.
But no, only specific
things can happen,
and they're controlled by
these specific coupling terms.
And you could calculate them.
Now there's an
interesting other thing.
I told you that the first-order
correction to the energy
is equal to a diagonal matrix
element of the correction term
to the Hamiltonian.
All of the second-order
terms involve
squares of matrix elements.
The second-order terms
you don't know the signs.
If there is a first-order
correction, you get the sine.
And sometimes you
know you want to know:
is the perturbation like that
or the perturbation like that?
Is there a barrier
or an extra well?
And this enables
you to know that
in second-order
perturbation theory when
you have to square
the matrix element,
all that information
is concealed.
Well, anyway-- so there is
a huge amount of algebra
that's involved in
using these equations.
And I don't really want to
go through that algebra.
You can read my notes.
I think the chances of you
reading those notes are small.
But if I don't lecture on them,
it would be slightly greater.
It's a complete treatment
of a two-mode problem
with all of the possible
and harmonic terms
cubic and quartic.
And everything worked out.
Now the trick is,
you could easily say,
well, the algebra
is just so horrible.
Why would I bother?
But what you do is
you take these terms
and you sort according
to selection rule.
So for example, here we
have a selection rule delta
V1 is plus or minus 1 and delta
V2 is plus or minus 2 and 0.
And so there are then six
possible selection rules
associated with
these sorts of terms.
And what you want to
do is do the algebra
that combines all this
horrible stuff according
to selection rule that leads to
simplification of the formulas.
And then once you've
got everything
sorted according
to selection rule,
then you can calculate
what happens.
I can't promise that
I will never give you
a two-mode problem
on an exam, but I
can promise I will give
you a one-mode problem.
And so you want
to really know how
to do these sorts of things.
So non-degenerate
perturbation theory
works when the energy
denominator is large compared
to the coupling matrix element.
And accidents occur
when you have, say,
a situation where omega
1 is approximately
equal to 2 omega 2.
Now this isn't
just blowing smoke.
This happens an
amazing number of times
because stretches are
higher frequency than bends.
And it's very common
for the bending modes
to be roughly half or
one third the frequency
of a stretching mode.
And so you get a resonance.
So this is special
because now it's
violating the
fundamental approximation
of non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
But it's a two-level
interaction.
And so you can say, I know
how to do a two-level problem.
I can solve that.
And these resonances have names.
There is a Fermi and there
is a Darling-Dennison.
The Fermi resonance was
discovered and understood
by Fermi.
And it has to do with CO2.
Omega 1 in CO2 is
approximately twice omega 2.
The symmetric stretch and the
bend are in Fermi resonance.
So what happens then?
Suppose we have a level
that involves V1, V2, V3.
And nearby there is a level
V1 minus 1 V2 plus 2 V3.
And because of the
energy denominators,
these two guys are
nearly degenerate.
So what happens is
one gets shifted up,
one gets shifted
down a little bit.
And they're out of the
expectation of smooth behavior.
And it might also be that this
state is what we call bright
and this is called dark.
This state might be connected
by an allowed transition
from a lower--
an initial state
and this might not.
So the levels repel
because they're interacting
and they're out of position.
And this guy is
supposed to be bright.
We're supposed to see a
transition in the spectrum.
And this one-- well, it should
have been somewhere else.
But we shouldn't see
it because it's dark.
It's forbidden.
But because of the interaction
between these two levels,
the eigenstates have
mixed character.
And you get both level
shifts and extra lines.
This is called a
spectroscopic perturbation.
This is the core
of everything I've
done for the last 45 years--
spectroscopic perturbations.
And so you can learn about
some of these coupling terms
because, instead of
hiding in the forest
of these small corrections,
you get a big effect.
And it's easy to
observe and it's
easy to determine each coupling
term from these resonances.
And the last thing
I want to talk
about today is a little
bit of philosophy.
This is why, among
spectroscopists
or physical chemists,
there are two communities--
communities that like small
molecules and communities
that like big molecules, because
they're really different.
For the small
molecule community,
you have this
accidental resonance
and you get this sort of thing.
For big molecules,
you have a resonance
with a dense manifold of levels.
All of these levels
share, say, the character
of the dark state.
And so they can all
interact with this guy.
And so in this case, you
get the main transition
in an extra line.
In this case, if you
have low resolution,
you get a broadened line.
And if you have high
enough resolution,
you see that there is a whole
bunch of eigenstates under it.
And if it's a large
enough molecule,
you couldn't
resolve them anyway.
And so some people are
always dealing with fast IVR,
fast dephasing of
the bright transition
into a dark manifold.
And other people
are always looking
at these sorts of things.
Now I like these
because they really
give you a lot of information.
Now you can get the
information you want from this
because the width of
this thing is related
to the number of dark states and
their average coupling matrix
element.
That's called
Fermi's golden rule.
We'll talk about that later.
So I think there's
a pretty good place
to stop because what I
try to do is to show you,
yes, it can be
really complicated.
But it's something
that you can do,
and you can project out
the coupling constants
that you want in order to
determine the stuff that
is relevant to your experiment.
But then there is this dichotomy
between small molecules
where the vibrational
density of states
is always smaller until you
get to really high energy.
And bigger molecules--
now they're not very big.
Benzene is plenty big
for this sort of thing.
And there is the question.
For example, in
some big molecules,
when you excite an electronic
transition from the ground
state to some excited state--
so here's S0, S1.
Sometimes you can't see
any fluorescence from S1
because the dephasing is so
fast that there's nothing.
And so it says,
well, tough luck.
You can't do
spectroscopy in emission.
But you can still see
the absorption spectrum
because then your signal
is the removal of photons
from your beam as
opposed to fluorescence.
So there's a huge amount of
photochemistry and interesting
stuff connected with a
large density of states.
And again, when I was
a graduate student,
there was a huge controversy
about non-radiative transitions
in medium sized molecules.
And there was one
community that says,
the collisions which transfer
population between levels
are so fast that, in order
to turn off this broadening,
you had to go to
really low pressure
because then there
wouldn't be collisions.
And the answer,
whenever somebody
failed to see sharp
spectra, was, well,
you're not at low
enough pressure.
But this has nothing
to do with collisions.
And that got resolved
by two gentlemen
called Bixon and Jortner.
Those are two names that any
educated physical chemist
will know to say, oh,
that's the Bixon-Jortner.
And they're still alive.
They're still doing
beautiful stuff.
But anyway, that's all
I want to say today.
I will do details on one
mode and Morse oscillator
in other sorts of
things next time.